all right one of the more interesting
questions about the classified documents
Scandal and when we explored a little
bit last night is that Biden is being
set up by forces out of control a new
report from The New York Times certainly
lends Credence to that story the
decision by President Biden and his
advisors to keep the discovery of
classified documents secret for 68 days
was driven by what turned out to be a
feudal hope that the justice department
would view the incident as a good faith
mistake
well perhaps that is why Biden was so
annoyed yesterday when declaring there's
no there there joining me now is
Kentucky Senator Rand Paul
Senator um do you subscribe to this
theory that there is or appears to be
some type of internal attempt to take
Biden out of the 2024 running
I think if you watch the news cycle
there's a startling difference in the
last week or two particularly over the
classified documents and perhaps over
some of the corruption charges with
Hunter Biden they've been steadfast and
ignoring this you know for years and
really not reporting on it at all I
think the fact that they're reporting on
it now if I had to guess if we were in
The Boardroom of some of these left-wing
medial it's what we'd be hearing is it's
time to sort of ease him out make sure
that he knows that he can't run again in
case he's rumbling that he might run
again I think most of us have suspected
that he wouldn't run again but I think
the Democrats and those in charge of the
Democrat uh wing of the press I think
they want to make sure that he's pushed
enough that he knows he can't run again
so they can start looking for a new
candidate more distrust is being
fostered by something we heard from the
FBI director Christopher Ray who is in
Davos yesterday watch this
the sophistication of the private sector
is is improving and and particularly
important the level of collaboration
between the private sector and the
government especially the FBI has I
think uh made significant strides
Senator quickly how alarming is it that
they're bragging about this
collaboration between the FBI and the
private sector
next week on our return I'll be
introducing legislation that will
prevent this collaboration there's no
limit to what we can do to government
there are limits to what we can do to
private businesses part of speech but to
the government we should and my
legislation will absolutely prevent this
collaboration the FBI should not be
meeting and discussing protected speech
your opinion on wearing a mask your
opinion on taking a vaccine this is
protected speech anything you say
politically religious otherwise opinions
are protected speech and the FBI should
not be allowed to collaborate in any
discussions that regulate protected
speech
Senator great to see you as always
tonight thanks so much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else